обнуляючи залужного який за всіма
соціологічними дослідженнями Сьогодні
має найвищий рейтинг довіри в
суспільстві вони обнуляли рейтинг
Президента рейтинг Зеленського Тому
потрібно було б
е дуже-дуже ретельно Проаналізувати цю
цю ситуацію президенту і розпочинати
чистку не зі зброєних сил Україна із
головкома а з зі свого найближчого
оточення яке му порадило такий спосіб
відносин публічних відносин з головкомом
це не додає нам насправді і це 100% буде
використовувати Російська Федерація тому
що для неї заложний на посаді головкома
є знаєте такою мішенню номер один адже
саме він
керував сектором оборони починаючи з
широкомасштабного вторкнення
тому мені дуже прикро те